hey guys today it is the 25th of June my
name is just McDonald and your
complimentary batman arkham knight for
PC watch is here to say that yes the
game is still messed up let's talk about
other things the first other thing is
that apparently so neat despite
announcing the Kickstarter during their
e3 press conference and eating
financially won't be seeing a cent of
Shenmue 3 kickstarter funding Shenmue
creator yu suzuki has said that funds
raised through the campaign will only go
to his studio YS net to aid development
although Suzuki has said that Sony will
provide assistance on production
marketing and publishing as for the game
itself suzuki has outlined a
five-million-dollar stretch goal which
will add a new gameplay feature and a 10
million dollar stretch goal to create a
quote much larger completely open world
according to bethesda doom 4 was
previously canceled and rebooted into
what we saw at e3 because it was too
similar to other shooters but those as
Pete Hines told polygon that doom 4
looked like too much of a departure from
classic doom he explains quote we
decided that it wasn't doom enough and
needed to be thrown out and started over
you can probably close your eyes and
imagine a call of doom or a battle dune
game where it starts to feel way too
much like wait this doesn't feel like
doom it feels like we're playing some
other franchise with a doom skin on it
more specifically he said the combat
often called for cover and the game was
overly dependent on common FPS elements
which simply wasn't what they wanted for
the next doom finally the witcher 3 4
consoles has received a small patch and
since the whole lot of you still seem to
be playing it here are the details patch
1.05 resolves a number of issues and
aims to improve overall performance
among the fixers are tweaks to the UI
all no longer resetting once you've hit
65,535 portions of clearance no longer
puffing up in the quick slot after
exhausting all up
edibles and a fix that stops girls
clothes being wet after you leave the
menus I've said it before and I'll say
it again RPG bugs and subsequently their
patch notes are hilarious let me know
down in the comments what you think of
the new zoom and be sure to hedge
against pot we've got stories on a new t
ablo 3 patch and bungee conceding to
fans over one of the Destiny deal speed
bottle those are all the things that I
wanted to tell you about today but be
sure to join me this same time tomorrow
for my top 5 stories of the whole gaming
week I'll see you then